[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
38 of the weekly Google
Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Francesc.
How are you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Very good, very good,
very happy to have a
repeating guest today.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Paul Newson is going
to be joining us again.
The first time he talked
to us about storage,
but now it's going to be
something totally different.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Apparently, he changed
teams for a little bit.
I'm hoping he will come back.
But yeah, he's going to be
sharing what he's being lately
up to, which is really cool.
So, yeah, very, very
interesting interview.
I was checking.
Yeah, that was episode 14.
MARK MANDEL: Oh.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Episode 14
storage with Paul Newson.
Episode 38 other stuff
with Paul Newson.
MARK MANDEL: It's like
if you divide it by 2,
it's exactly twice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No.
MARK MANDEL: My math
is totally wrong.
Numbers are hard.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
OK, anyway, so yeah,
we're going to be talking with
Paul Newson about his new role
as an SRE and what
it is to be an SRE.
And then we have the
question of the week,
which is guess what again?
MARK MANDEL: A little
bit about Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Nope, not this time.
Well, actually Google
Container Engine,
so yes, it is Kubernetes again.
It is about how to upgrade your
Kubernetes-- your Container
Engine-- I forgot.
MARK MANDEL: Cluster.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Clusters.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: To newest
versions and how to do that.
But before that,
we're going to be
talking about two cool
things of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
we have a couple
of really great announcements.
First of all, we released a
whole new API under our cloud
machine learning spectrum,
cloud natural language API--
which is really cool-- and
their cloud speech APIs.
They work hand in hand.
It's pretty sweet.
You can send
basically audio to it
and it's able to basically
take the text-- go speech
to text, which is
really awesome,
but also do things like
sentiment analysis, entity
recognition, syntax
analysis, to do way
more stuff that I can understand
about the English language
and various other
languages as well,
and break it down into verbs and
adverbs, and what's important
and what's not, and do all sorts
of other fun things with it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it is very cool.
And one of the things
that I really love
is these entity analysis,
which sounds abstract.
But it is able to
tell you things
like if you have a text
that says oh, yeah,
last year I went
to the Big Apple.
It will tell you,
oh, the Big Apple.
Do you mean New York?
It will actually make those
links, which is pretty amazing.
It is not just
basic text analysis.
It's way more than that.
It is very impressive.
MARK MANDEL: It is
really impressive.
The other thing
that we announced
is a whole new region.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yes, because why not?
MARK MANDEL: Why not?
Like we don't have enough
data centers or computers.
So, we now have a
region in US West.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yep, and we're going
to be talking a little
bit more about that
during the interview, because
apparently our colleague, Paul,
was somehow related to this.
So, yeah, very interesting.
MARK MANDEL: It's pretty cool.
I'm just reading now that
initial testing shows
that users in Vancouver,
Seattle, Portland, San
Francisco, and Los Angeles
can expect to see a 30% to 80%
reduction in latency.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty good.
Can't complain about that.
Excellent, so that seems
like some cool stuff,
but why don't we do some
other cool things like go talk
to Paul?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
let's go to that.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good to me.
-So, I'm very happy to
introduce Paul Newson.
Hey, Paul.
How are you doing?
PAUL NEWSON: I'm doing great.
How are you?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very happy to
have you back to the podcast.
We had you a long
time ago when you
used to be a developer
advocate to talk about storage.
I didn't even know
what episode was that.
MARK MANDEL: It
was really early.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It was like--
PAUL NEWSON: I think
it was a single digit.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
PAUL NEWSON: I think
it was that early.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That was
like years ago, I think.
MARK MANDEL: A lifetime ago.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And now you're back.
You're not a developer
advocate anymore.
So, who are you?
What do you do?
Hi, Paul.
PAUL NEWSON: So, my
name's Paul Newson,
and I am indeed still
a developer advocate,
but I'm doing this really cool
rotation program called mission
control where I get to
be a Google SRE, which
is a Site Reliability Engineer
for approximately six months.
And I get to learn what Site
Reliability Engineering is all
about.
It's something I've been really
curious about for a long time.
I've been at Google now a
little over six years, I think.
And for the first
few years I was here,
I was a software engineer
on cloud storage.
And at the end of my time there,
I was really curious about SRE.
And I nearly did a
mission control rotation,
but instead I decided to
turn left instead of right
and became a developer advocate
and ended up on a team with you
folks.
And so, a couple,
a few months back
I was having a
great conversation
with Brian Dorsey-- who
you both obviously know
about-- how difficult
it is to talk
about reliability
with our customers
as a developer advocate.
I mean, it's hard to describe.
What is the conversation
you can have about that?
And I realized
what I really like
to be able to do is talk
about Site Reliability
Engineering at
Google, but I just
don't feel like I know enough
to have that conversation.
I didn't feel like I could
really represent the whole Site
Reliability
Engineering philosophy
and approach to
reliability really well.
So, then I hit on the idea of
maybe now's the time for me
to do this mission
control rotation
and really learn what
this is all about.
So, that's what I did, and
I started on that in May--
and I guess it's July now so
I'm a couple of months in.
And so, it's still
just the beginning.
One of the things that I'm
excited to do while I'm
on this rotation is write about
it on the Google Cloud Platform
Blog.
So, I did that a couple of
weeks ago, I think, and now I'm
here talking to you
guys on the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that blog post was amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I really loved it.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
So, let's find out what is
a Site Reliability Engineer?
PAUL NEWSON: So, Site
Reliability Engineering
is, to quote Ben
Treynor, it's what
happens when you put a
software engineer in charge
of an operations function.
So, the history
of the term-- he's
the one who coined the
phrase, because they wanted
to have a phrase, or a
name, or a title for what
do we call these software
engineers who aren't building
features into the
product but are instead
concerned with making sure
the product can scale up
and making sure that
the product is reliable,
and doing all of that in
a sustainable way that
doesn't burn people out.
And that's what Site
Reliability Engineering
was meant to capture.
Other companies may call it SRE.
They may call it something else.
Broadly, it is an
operations function.
We think we add a
little twist to it that
at least was novel at the time.
DevOps is also mixed in there.
It's all in the we're
not building features.
We're talking about how you do
something like this reliably,
and well, and scalably.
So, that's what, in a
not so brief nutshell,
Site Reliability
Engineering is about.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's a role
that I really like at Google,
because it's-- I think very
different to what other people
expect from DevOps.
I know that SRE people
write lots of code.
They deal with a
great amount of code.
But my favorite thing about
them is you have SRE jackets.
PAUL NEWSON: I don't
have an SRE jacket.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You
don't have it yet.
You better get one.
Those are amazing.
PAUL NEWSON: Well, I'll tell
them you said so, Francesc,
so that now they
have to give me one,
because you said it
publicly on the podcast
that I should get one.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
PAUL NEWSON: So, maybe
that's just what I need.
But yeah, there's a badge.
It's a leather jacket.
You can choose your style.
There's a few different
styles, and there's a badge
that you can put on it which
is modeled after the badges
that they would
have at NASA mission
control for each mission.
They would have a mission
patch for each mission, which
I think the
astronauts would wear,
and then they would have a
mission patch for the mission
control people as well.
And so, somebody
came up with the idea
long ago that, wow,
it would be really
cool to have that style of patch
on a jacket just to show, hey,
we're SREs.
We keep Google up.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
those are really cool.
And the patch has a slogan?
PAUL NEWSON: Yes, and I'm not
going to try and pronounce
the Latin, because--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, come on, try.
PAUL NEWSON: No, no.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Come
on, you're from Canada.
They speak Latin
up there, I think.
PAUL NEWSON: But it's
based on the motto
that Gene Kranz coined
for mission control, which
I believe is-- oh man.
You'd think I'd
have this by heart.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Because
hope is not a strategy.
Is it that one?
PAUL NEWSON: That
is a different one.
Hope is not a strategy is a
slogan-- is an unofficial SRE
slogan, but this one
is tough and competent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, OK, cool.
PAUL NEWSON: That was the
mission control slogan,
and that's what's
on the actual patch.
But hope is not a
strategy is also
one of the things
that is an SRE slogan.
And the philosophy there being
is anything that can go wrong
will go wrong, pretty much.
And hoping it won't go wrong
is not a viable strategy
when you do things at the
scale that Google does.
Because at some point, if
you have enough servers doing
enough things in
enough data centers,
then something that
happens once in a million
is happening
constantly at Google,
because we're doing millions and
millions of millions of things
all the time.
So those very,
very rare bugs that
might hit a small service once
a year could hit us once a day
or once a minute.
So, hope is not a strategy is a
very important slogan for SRE.
MARK MANDEL: Sometimes you
even get struck by lightning
four times in a row.
PAUL NEWSON: Yes.
And then it happens
a second time.
MARK MANDEL: But
one thing I love
about that is I just know
that there is probably
an SRE or a hardware ops person
somewhere who's like all right,
now we need to protect
us against [INAUDIBLE].
There's someone with that
plan with a document saying
this is what we need to
prevent against going forward.
PAUL NEWSON: So, you can't
predict every failure.
That's an interesting thing.
So, what you want to do is
have a culture and a process
for dealing with whatever it
is that comes up, because you
can't predict everything.
You're going to in fact--
this job would be extremely
boring if all we ever did was
respond to the same problems
over and over again.
It's actually an explicit
goal that we should never
have the same problem twice,
because we had it once already.
We did a post-mortem on it, we
figured out why it happened,
and we fixed whatever that was.
So, every time the
pager goes off,
it should be a new and novel
thing you've never seen before.
So, that's what you
have to practice for.
You can't practice for
the specific scenario.
You have to work on things that
are generic across problems,
across incidents, like you
need a good instant response
method that people understand.
I can't speak to that
right now because I
haven't learned that part.
I'm currently embedded with the
Google Compute Engine SRE team.
And one of my goals
for this quarter
is to be trained
up to go on call,
so hopefully I can go
on call next quarter.
But currently, I don't
understand the incident
response process
that we have here.
So, I'm not going to
pretend to say something
intelligent about it here on the
podcast, but I know it exists
and I see it in
action and I watch.
I was thinking this
morning, actually,
anticipating this
interview, and I
was thinking I feel like
we should have t-shirts
that say keep calm and SRE.
Because it's kind of this very--
even when stuff is going wrong,
people are pretty chill because
it's like this is the job.
And people are set
up to succeed in it.
You have the resources.
You have the backup.
You're not out
there by yourself,
and it happens all the time.
MARK MANDEL: It's kind of like
being on call for-- like you're
part of emergency services.
Your job is to put out fires
or your job is to save people.
Your job is to
basically sit there
and say, OK, things are going
to go wrong all the time
and our job is to make sure that
they go as best as they can.
PAUL NEWSON: And that's really
half the job, I would say.
And this is a really,
really important thing
to understand about
SRE-- and probably I
would say more broadly modern
operations of large scale
services.
So, let's do a
thought experiment.
You ship a service that runs
and it's running on 10 servers,
and you need to pay
one person full time
to do manual things to those
servers to keep them up.
We call that toil where
it's something that you do.
It's necessary.
It's important.
But basically what
you're doing is
you're returning the
service to a good state.
And now you get lots
of new customers
and you have 20 servers.
Now you need two people
to do that, assuming
your toil scales with the
number of servers you have.
Then let's say you
don't add servers.
Let's say you have these really
sharp developers who come up
with these awesome
new features and they
deploy these new features, and
that increases the surface area
of the product.
The product got bigger,
even though it's not
more servers or more users.
So, now you're growing
in multiple dimensions.
If you need to scale, the
number of people doing
toil on your service with
the number of servers,
or the number of users,
or the amount of traffic,
or the amount of features,
then eventually you're
going to have an ops team
which is unsustainably huge.
You won't be able to
hire enough people
to take care of your service.
So, I would almost say the
more important role of SRE--
we're well known for-- we carry
the pager for the services
we support.
We are on the front lines.
That's what everybody thinks of.
Even internally at
Google, usually that's
what everyone thinks of
when they think of SRE.
But we spend less than half
of our time doing that.
And we spend more
than half of our time
writing code and doing
engineering work so
that the toil does not scale
with the size of the service.
Let's take Google Compute
Engine as an example.
Our usage is growing.
That's probably not a secret.
And we are constantly
launching new features.
Just look at the
Cloud Platform Blog.
So we're growing in
all the dimensions
that you can imagine.
The product is growing
much, much, much faster
than the size of the
SRE team supporting it.
In fact, the size of the
SRE team supporting it
is roughly constant, if
you look at the feature set
that one team is supporting.
So, how is it possible
that the service can
get so much bigger
and the team that
is on the front lines on
call for it doesn't grow?
Well, that's because that
team is constantly doing work
to make the service
easier to keep up,
easier to monitor, easier so
that things that might have
happened a year ago that
required manual intervention--
it just happened now.
We have programs for that.
If it's something
that you can do
without really discerning
human judgment,
you just write a
program for that
and then it does it for you.
If you know what
the solution is,
you just write a program
for it, and then you
deploy that program,
and then you
make sure that program's up.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
reminds me of the joke
if you're not good I'll
replace you with a script.
It's something like that.
Basically, that is your job.
PAUL NEWSON: Exactly.
We don't want to hire more SREs
to do the same thing that we're
doing.
We want to write scripts
for what we're doing today,
and then go do something
interesting tomorrow
that we haven't done before.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So,
talking about things
that are interesting, you
said that you're not on call
and that you're
doing all the things.
One of those things is actually
a pretty amazing thing.
It is a new region on
Google Cloud Platform.
PAUL NEWSON: That's correct.
I had the privilege of
being peripherally involved
in the unveiling of our new
us-west1 region this past week,
which was a really
great experience.
And I want to be
super clear here
that many, many,
many other people did
tons, and tons, and tons
of work over many weeks
to actually bring
up a new region.
Servers need to actually arrive
at places and be put in racks,
and all kinds of services need
to be turned up and monitored
on those things.
And then the very, very, very
last step is we flick a switch,
and now it appears to
the world and everybody
can see all this
hard work that's
happened over a period of time.
So, my part in that was I
got to be somewhat involved
in flipping the
switch, so to speak,
because something that
I'd been working on
was how we do configuration
changes for our Google Compute
Engine.
Let me step back a second.
Any change you make to your
service carries some risk.
If you want a 100% reliable
service never change anything
and then it won't break.
But that's not what
customers want.
Customers want new regions.
Customers want new features.
We need to do these things,
because even if we tried
to stay static, our
customers wouldn't.
They would bring
new workloads to us.
So, we're constantly modifying
and changing the system.
And the interesting
part is how do you
do that as safely as possible?
So, I was involved
with, all right,
we're going to unveil
this new region.
How do we want to do this?
What are the series of
steps we want to go through.
What are the checks and
balances along the way,
and how long do we want
to take, things like that.
And so, I got to be involved
in defining that process, which
was mostly just
writing down stuff
I'd learned from all
the people around me
in the past couple of months.
But I just happened
to be the person who
was collecting that information
then presenting it as a plan.
And then people much more
knowledgeable and experienced
than I said, yes,
this plan makes sense.
Go do it.
And then I wasn't even the
one flipping the switch,
because if you're going to
modify a production service,
the person who
should be doing that
is the person who's on call.
So, I essentially
presented this plan
to the people who
happened to be on call,
who happened to be carrying the
pager at that moment in time.
I said, all right, here's
how we're going to do this,
and then they went and did it.
So, it was lots of fun.
I really enjoyed it.
Now, I want to get more involved
in how we turn up regions
and be involved in one
from beginning to end.
We've announced that we're
going to do a lot of these
over the next year or so.
So, there should be
lots of opportunity
for me to get involved in that.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
I have a small question for
you from earlier, because I'm
actually just curious.
You talked about doing
a rotation through SRE.
Do people normally do rotations?
Do they come and they go, or
is it a permanent position?
How does that normally work?
PAUL NEWSON: So SRE is
usually a permanent position,
but we have this thing called
the mission control program,
because a lot of
software engineers
who have worked at other
companies come to Google
and they come to Google
as a software engineer.
And they may be
interested in how
to run a service at
really high scale
kind of like I was
when I came here,
but they may have come from a
culture where operations is not
as well regarded and where
the operations function is not
as well supported
as it is at Google.
So, they may be hesitant
to become an SRE.
They might think, man, I
don't want to carry the pager.
That just sounds like
it's going to be draining.
It's going to take
over my whole life.
So, this is a way for
them to come into SRE,
learn all about it, get
trained up, carry the pager,
and see if this is something
that they like to do.
And what often they
discover along the way is,
wow, real engineering
work happens here.
I'm still writing
code most of the time,
but I'm also doing
these really cool things
with these huge systems
that I can't believe
they let me touch this stuff.
It's fantastic.
And then they have
the experience
of carrying the pager and
they realize, oh, Google
understands how to make being
on call a sustainable thing that
doesn't ruin your life.
We have the advantage of
being a global company.
So, the Google
Compute Engine team
that I'm embedded
with, for example,
is in our Seattle office,
but we have a sister team
in the London office, which is
conveniently about eight time
zones away.
So, when we're sleeping
they're on call,
and when they're
sleeping we're on call.
It makes it far more sustainable
than the typical you're
the ops guy.
Here's your pager.
It could ring at any time.
Good luck to you.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I still
have stress-induced dreams
of getting woken up at
4 o'clock in the morning
to battle some fire that
happens on some server.
PAUL NEWSON: Right, and
that's not how we do it here,
because it's not sustainable.
Our management in SRE views SREs
as a rare and valuable resource
that-- it's hard to
hire into this position.
And once we have somebody
in this position,
we want to take care
of them and make sure
that they want to
stay in that position,
because we can't
possibly hire enough.
This is the other
reason why we need
to make sure that we don't need
to scale the number of SREs
with the size of our services,
because we couldn't possibly
hire enough, if that's
what we were doing.
So, we have guidelines
around how many incidents
an on-caller should be taken
care of in a particular shift.
Then if it goes above a
certain threshold, that's
a warning sign that this
service is now not sustainable
and we need to stop
focusing on features
or shift our focus from
launching new features to make
this a more sustainable service,
because if we don't, it's
going to run away.
These feel like the
slippery slopes.
If once you get a certain
velocity of unmanageability,
then suddenly
you're spending all
of your time trying to deal
with the unmanageability
and you can't make
progress anymore.
So, we have these metrics which
we review on a regular basis.
How many incidents are
we seeing per shift?
Are our engineers
spending a majority
of their time
actually doing work
to make the service more
maintainable, more sustainable
versus just doing manual toil?
And so, coming back to the
mission control rotation
you get into SRE
and you realize,
wow, Google has figured
out how to make this work.
And not only that, this is fun.
This is rewarding.
I like the people
I'm doing it with.
This is great.
I want to keep doing this.
I'm not scared of it anymore.
So, roughly half the software
engineers who come through--
and software engineer
from a development team
who previously had been
working on launching new
features roughly speaking who
come through a mission control
rotation, they choose to stay
as SREs after the rotation
and that becomes
their permanent job.
There's other
people who are just
hired straight into SRE because
they were doing SRE-like work
at another company.
Or maybe they just
take the plunge
and they say I
really want to get
my hands on these huge services
and they make the plunge.
But to answer your question,
the mission control rotation
program is officially
a rotation program
that lasts for six months.
But really what it is is a
chance to experience SRE,
and then you get to make
a choice at the end.
SRE would probably
love to have you stay,
but you can always go back to
a typical development position
as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Or
developer advocacy.
PAUL NEWSON: Or in my
case, developer advocacy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We want you back.
MARK MANDEL: I was
going to say, now
I'm a little worried
we're going to lose you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I have a couple
of questions regarding this.
The first one is you said that
you still write a lot of code.
And you know my question now.
What language?
PAUL NEWSON: Oh, well you'll be
happy to hear, Francesc, that I
am currently learning Go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There you go.
PAUL NEWSON: Because
the system that I
will be enhancing with new
features is written in Go.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
PAUL NEWSON: And Go is a very
popular language among SREs
for all reasons I
probably don't need
to tell you, Francesc, other
than just being awesome.
It's also very fast, but it's
because previously Python
was very popular among SREs,
mostly because of that really
fast iterative development.
And with Go, you
get that but it's
not an interpreted language,
which personally I'm
going to expose my bias now.
I really like languages that
actually compile to something
and where types have meaning,
and I'm not getting type errors
at runtime-- my personal bias.
Use the tools you like, but
I'm a C programmer at heart,
so Go makes me very, very happy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And you were saying
that it is hard to
hire SREs, and that
is why when Google
hires SREs, we
try to keep them as
happy as possible.
What are the skills
you think are
the most important to have to
become an SRE or to be a good
SRE?
PAUL NEWSON: Well, I'm going
to try an accurately repeat
things I've heard others
say, because I don't
feel I'm really
qualified to give
my own answer to this question.
But we sort of have two types
of people who typically come in
and interview for SRE
and are successful
and become successful SREs.
One is what you would expect
from pretty much applying
to a software engineering role
at Google, same skill set.
You're a software engineer.
You know how to write code.
You know how to
architect systems.
Hopefully you have some
distributed systems knowledge.
Those people can come in
and become successful SREs.
And, in fact, most
people that are
coming through the
mission control program
fit that profile.
Then there's what they
call the system engineer.
That's what they call it.
And these are people who may
not have the formal software
engineering background.
Maybe they didn't graduate from
a computer science or computer
engineering program,
but they have
been architecting and building
and operating large scale
systems as part of their work
and part of their career.
And they come in with
a particular mindset
and a set of experiences,
which is super valuable.
And so, there's a path for
them as well within SRE,
both in terms of being hired
and progressing in their career.
And what we've found
is that it really
doesn't matter which of
those two profiles you meet.
These people who may not have
the formal software engineering
or computer science
background, they're
still writing code today.
Lots of people write code who
don't have that background,
and there's lots of people
who do it very well who
don't have that background.
And they come in and they make
equally good contributions,
but they also tend to
bring a set of experiences
and knowledge of low level
systems and often networking,
which is super useful to SRE.
And then these two
populations mix together
and everyone learns from each
other, and it's fantastic.
MARK MANDEL: Cool,
all right, well, we're
start to run out of
time, unfortunately.
This is a great conversation.
But before we run
off, is there anything
you'd like to
mention, or touch on,
or something we may have
missed in our questions
that you want to say?
PAUL NEWSON: Oh, let's see.
Oh, yeah, there's
a couple things.
One is take everything
you've heard here
with a grain of salt.
This is obviously
just my opinion based on
a few weeks of hanging out
with these people and
I'm not an expert on SRE,
so please bear that in mind.
But there's also a
couple of other resources
I'd like to point
people towards.
At SREcon14, I
believe, Ben Treynor
gave a talk where he walked
through the principles of SRE.
And a great deal of what
I've told you here today
I learned from watching that
talk and other talks like it.
So, if this is an
interesting topic to you,
it would be very well worth
45 minutes of your time to go
watch Ben Treynor
talk about this
instead of listening to me.
And then if that really
whets your appetite
and you really want
to go deep, there
was a book released recently
called "Site Reliability
Engineering," and
that's a great read.
I'm still working
my way through it.
I don't know all
the material in it.
And I think there's a lot
of good wisdom in there.
It was written by people
who are SREs at Google.
It's a series of essays on a
series of important topics.
I think there's a lot of
really good knowledge in there.
So, that would be a
fantastic resource.
And then finally, if you
are interested in this topic
but don't have the
time to read the book
or can't set aside
the 45 minutes,
just keep watching the
Google Cloud Platform Blog,
because I hope to publish more
little nuggets of my experience
there in a way that won't take
you hours and hours to consume
where I can introduce
some of the concepts
and some of the aha moments
I've had along the way,
and maybe you can share.
Because I'm on this journey
from not understanding this
stuff to hopefully
understanding this stuff.
And I hope to publish
some of those aha moments
along the way when I have
these realizations about what's
important and what's
cool, and maybe you
can vicariously share in
those with me on the blog.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Excellent.
That is great.
We have links to every
single one of those things
that you said in the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
But Paul, thanks so much
for coming to join us today.
It's been an absolutely
fascinating conversation.
PAUL NEWSON: It's my
pleasure, and maybe we
can do this again
maybe in the new year
after I've had my rotation and I
can correct all of the mistakes
that I made in this interview
and add more detail.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
think that's a deal.
MARK MANDEL: Done.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
Great, thank you so much.
PAUL NEWSON: You're welcome.
Thanks.
Good talking to you guys.
MARK MANDEL: Cheers.
That was an amazing
conversation with Paul.
Thanks so much to him for
coming and joining us today.
I'd learned so much
more about SREs
than I think I even imagined
I would, so it was awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I'm very happy that he
was the one proposing
that he will come back
before he finishes rotation,
because he's totally
doing that.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We'll
have him back again.
That's for sure.
MARK MANDEL: 100%.
But why do we get into our
question of the week which
is looking at when you have a
container engine cluster set up
on GKE.
Obviously new versions
of Kubernetes come up
and you want to upgrade to them.
How do you handle that?
I know part of it automated,
part of it is not.
How do you manually
process that through
and make sure you have the
least amount of down time
and manage that within your
schedule for your application?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So, yeah, that
is a question that many people
ask quite often.
So, one of our
coworkers, Terry Ryan,
wrote a blog post
about it, and we'll
have a link on
the show as usual.
But basically the answer
is, OK, so the master
of your-- the masters will
be upgraded automatically
at some point not too long
after the new version has
been released.
The master will be
rebooted and you
don't need to care about this.
Everything just happens.
It's invisible, it's
magic, and it's beautiful.
Now, we don't do this for nodes.
Why?
Well, because imagine that
you are getting a huge amount
of traffic and at
that moment we decide
that is a perfect moment to
restart your nodes-- not great.
So, you can restart them
either by just restarting them.
You will get a new
node, and that new node
will have the new
version of current IDs,
or also you have a way
to upgrade manually.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, there's
a series of gcloud commands,
like upgrade commands.
And you can also do it through
the web interface as well.
It says in our documentation
it says generally you
want to be upgrading
in a timely manner.
Nodes that are more
than two minor versions
behind the master may
not work properly.
So, you should be
upgrading your nodes.
But yeah, the blog post covers
the several different ways
you can do it and how you
can make your upgrades happen
in a timely fashion.
It also has some discussion of
things like node pools and what
not, what to do when you
have volumes mounted,
and how to manage that, and
some other minor points as well.
It's pretty comprehensive.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I really like the fact
that the easiest way
to upgrade a node pool
or even a master is to just go
to the information on Google
on the console, and you
click on upgrade available
and that's it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
is incredibly simple.
But, of course, if you want
to do it through gcloud
so you can write your
own script or whatever,
that is totally doable
and very simple.
And we also explain how
to do it on the blog post.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
So, before we run away, I know
that you're not necessarily
traveling anywhere but you
have a new video series.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yes, that is true.
Yeah, there is-- I'm
sure that some of you
know MPJ from FunFunFunction.
So, basically I'm just
copying him and doing
slightly different things but--
MARK MANDEL: Inspired by.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
totally inspired by him.
So, if you don't know
him, go check it out.
He's on many videos.
And basically what I'm trying to
do is just me hacking on stuff,
or the first episode is
actually not even hacking.
It's I saw some code
in the wild on GitHub
and decided that it needed
some code reviews, so it's
a video of myself doing a 35
minute code review talking
about how to improve
[INAUDIBLE] code.
And the name is Just for Funk,
because funk like functioning
go.
Yeah, I'm pretty
happy with that.
MARK MANDEL: That's a good one.
I like it.
Excellent.
Well, I will be-- I'll actually
be in the middle of Australia
when this episode comes
out, but after that, I
will be at PAX Dev in--
what is that, late August?
And then mid-September I
will be at Strange Loop,
hopefully doing something.
I haven't quite
worked out what yet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Strange Loop is a
real cool conference.
MARK MANDEL: It is a
really cool conference.
They have unsessions
there, so if anyone
has any suggestions for an
unsession that they might want
to see, please send it through.
I'd be interested in maybe
putting something together
based on that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Well, I think we're out
of time, so I'm just
going to thank you again for
taking the time to interview
our awesome colleague Paul.
MARK MANDEL: And thank you
for spending the time with me
as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And thank
you to all our listeners
for listening to us.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely, and
we'll see you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See ya.
[MUSIC PLAYING]